hello everyone before me Cal Thailand
Rishikesh Medina
there was the Austrian chess player
Rudolph Spillman and well he was quite a
chess romantic his his limbs were always
well pretty crazy and full of full of
sacrifices and well liked morphic he was
also a lawyer although he never worked
as one but this game here it was played
in 1909 in Munich Germany and his
playing against some elite attacker and
it's not one of humans craziest games
but it really shows after one loss of a
simple tempo how Ullman jumps right into
the attack and you could you could find
it useful if you have a frame for
example that plays the caro-kann defense
well you could get an idea or two from
this game so let's see the game
Spillman is white and Tata cover is
black we have E for c6 so the car con
defense d4 d5 like to see 3d captures
only for knife captures any for the main
line nice to have six and now Knight the
back to g3 and we have E 5 here a very
sharp idea well some somewhat better
would be maybe c5 but ok
he plays d5 and Knight to f3 much
Pillman of course you don't want to
capture this pawn although it seems like
it's a free pawn if he captures an e5
simply queen capture Cindy one would
check Queen Kappa King captures and
Knight to g4 threatening Knight captures
an f2 for King the king and the rook and
after defend this you have to play a
move like Knight to h3 simply and I
captures the pawn back white doesn't
really achieve anything here so after E
5 matter if 3 is played and we have eke
after Sun before not after Sun before
and Bishop to c5 and this is very
interesting here Spillman plays Bishop
to e3 but 18 years after this game was
played Alexander alliant played a queen
to e to check and it's interesting that
he played the Queen to e to check
against Saudi tartar cover as well but
it's interesting that the engine is also
suggesting a move Queen to e to check
so it seems the election worked
to improve on this game a real man
played but okay Schumann played Bishop
to e3 we have Queen to b6 now adding
pressure to this night and before and
also attacking the spawn and b2 we have
Queen to e2 now and tafakkur castles you
can't capture the night here because
well you don't win a piece you lose the
Queen after this discovered Queen a
check from the Queen comes so after
Queen etutor talk over castles and we
have queenside castle by Spielman and
well this is a pretty much the critical
moment in the game
I probably rookie eight here would be
perfectly fine for black maybe even
Knight to g4
but what tactic over played was Knight
to d5 and it seems like okay he's
threatening some ideas he's attacking
this Bishop on III also night before
might be an idea but this is what what
Spillman means when he when he senses a
loss of a tempo
he plays Queen to h5 and you don't if
you if you're playing against real film
and you don't want to allow a move like
Queen to h5 it doesn't even have to be
the best move but it's like it's like
when you're playing against ow don't
don't give him anything to grab on
so here well probably maybe Knight to d7
can be played also Bishop to e6 could be
played but tartakov er admits his
mistake as he says night that if I
wasn't a good move and he plays Knight
back to f6 now would an attack on the
Queen but also it kind of was a loss of
a tempo
Queen to h4 is played and now Bishop to
g4 and here Spillman goes for his famous
initiative he doesn't mind this rook and
e1 being attacked he plays Bishop to d3
adding one more piece to the attack now
I aimed at age 7 square we have
Bishop capture somebody one rock capture
son d1 and now Knight B to d7 is played
and here we have Knight to f5 sorry nigt
to f5 and to talk cover wasn't really
aware of the danger that Spillman
prepared probably best move here would
be King to h8 probably not the best the
only move probably will be king
to h8 to allow this rook to come help
with the defense of the of the diva of
the G file but we have Knights to e5 by
try to cover and here
Spillman goes for if he plays Knight
captures on g7 and here what do you play
as black
well can you capture the night if King
captures night on g7 then Knight to f5
check King to g8 and we have Queen
captures on f6 check and you can't
defend checkmate on g7 you can prolong
it maybe Bishop captures on e3 f
captures and e3 Queen captures any on e3
and well why doesn't even have to
capture the Queen he can simply play
Queen to be one and again black cannot
stop checkmate the joke is on him
so after Knight captures and g7 we have
Queen to d8 Knight G to f5 is played now
Knight g6 attacking the Queen and
Spillman goes Queen to h6 now again were
threatening checkmate on g7 98 defending
the g7 square and now another nice move
by Spillman Knight to f3
the threat is pretty simple Knight
coming to g5 would a threat of Queen to
h7 checkmate
we have Bishop captures on e3 f captors
and e3 and now Queen to f6 is played we
have nice the g5 now threatening
checkmate m h7 only way to defend h7 is
Queen to h8 and now Freemont simply
plays Knight to e7 check and in this
position well sadly that Aquifer
resigned to the game as there is no
defense against this if you capture the
night well knife capture 77 you get
Bishop captures on h7 only move is Queen
captures and this is checkmate so yeah
but after 97 check talk will resign the
game so yeah a beautiful game by the
master of by the master of attack root
of Spielman if any of you are interested
in you know attacking chess and
sacrifices root of Spillman even wrote a
book the art of sacrifices in chess or
the art of sacrifice and chess I don't
know if it's plural so yeah I do hope
you enjoyed this game
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here I would like to
thank Greta rowdy Southgate Tom Ibis or
Bezier glue Carlos Gomez and Robert
elearning for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and yeah thank y'all for
watching guys and I will see you soon